I like ice
Rita
welcome back
thank you very much I appreciate it how
you been it's been a lot it's been about
a year or so since I've seen you yep
it's been great
in the area I stand I'm very blessed and
I'm very happy
to feel very safe you're in a much safer
neighborhood than scooters very safe and
very recently you've been there for how
long now I've been there going on two
years June the 18th two years yes
no drugs no drugs I did drugs in a year
going on going on yeah drama and Bs no
no no no no none of that how do you
spend your time now I spend my time with
the Lord and sharing my story My Life
and helping kids
to not live like I came
you telling your story telling my story
and tell them how to appreciate their
parents and how to live a better life
you know to not follow the road that I
went through
well you guys you had some rough breaks
that weren't they were out of your
control yeah you know I work with um
kindergartens to sixth grade
tell me about the community you're in
the community I am is very respectful
very very respectful more loving and
child of God and they very caring
and you feel very safe
that's great you deserve it tell me
about the the years that you spent how
many years were you down here I was here
since uh 2000 I spent almost all my life
in here on ski Road really yes
the last two years when I met you is
when my life got back together
you're down here so long I didn't
realize that yeah
I was on the streets sleeping in corners
and tires
but yes I'm very blessed since I met you
I it ain't been no problem
I I got a life now I'm back to my life
you and God anyway
if a person really need help you the one
that could really help them when it
comes to a place to live yeah you did a
lot of the work on your part too you you
straighten your act out really yeah I
was ready I've been ready before I met
you really but what I've learned now is
a lot of these people might say they
want help and all that and
have a good story to tell but they won't
really follow through with it yeah no
they can't accept anything yeah I'm for
reals I will definitely so you're
happier you look healthier I am very
happy and very healthy
you eat well you have friends down there
and things like that yes I do I have
religious Christian friends
it's not the race it's the grace of God
but mostly more of my happiness Latinos
than men
Caucasian oh really yes but it's a few
Stone brothers and sisters I treat
everybody the same they treat me it's
not the race it's the grace of God
religion's always been a part of your
life
always
you got lost for a while here yes as
soon as I got to California I thought it
was a parade with those things but it
was people smoking crack and I got
involved
you're smoking crack for how long
since how it was
35
how old do you know I'll be 60 in two
months January 13th
you don't ever want to come back down
here again dude never no and I don't
miss anything down here what do you
think
the problem is for all these people that
are stuck down here the drugs yeah I
believe it's the drugs
nothing but the drugs
yeah until they until they put that down
yeah exactly
until they believe in God hear it
because he the only one could do it
trusting God
take one step
and uh Rita what would you say you know
you've been through a lot a lot of ups
and downs in your life what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in all of this the most
important that I learned was stay
sobering clean
and healthy
simple as that yeah those that's all
that matters and keep God in my life
keep my father in my life
you want to sing for us huh you're
singing in the church right yeah
I got
I've seen through my phone my Mo my
thing oh really and I don't got it yeah
okay you should come on Pico and 12th
you and anyone who's welcome on to go
Pico and 12. I sing on the corner right
there by the alley dogs
every Saturday I have my own little
Simone
send them off okay really yes and you're
singing the church too yeah I sing in
the church right there on the corner of
62nd and Compton um
excellent Rita thank you so much for
coming back and visiting me yeah filling
Us in on what's going on in your life
I'm happy that you're uh that you're
happy and I'm happy to see you still got
it together and I'm happy to be here and
know that somebody do care I'm happy you
got out I do thank you very much thank
you you too God bless you